alors on le sait barack obama va entamer
son mandat dans des conditions très
difficiles le pays traverse l'une des
pires crises économiques de son histoire
tout le monde est touché et notamment
les seniors la retraite a été relevé
récemment à 67 ans mais le système ne
permet pas de vivre correctement et
certains malgré leur âge sont obligés de
retravailler pour s'en sortir
le reportage de stéphanie des jarres et
samuel guy bout il y à l'amérique des
affaires et de la puissance est liée à
celle des gens pour qui l'argent est un
problème quotidien dans leur maison
surchauffée qui lui ont toujours pas
finie payer yan et ken regarde souvent
les photos de leur voyage c'est le temps
de la vie facile yann etc et dépensent
sans compter oublie d'épargné pour leurs
vieux jours
mais quand il ya un arrêt de travail et
dans l'imprimerie à 71 ans le couple se
rend vite compte que la seule pension de
retraite versées par l'état ne leur
permet même pas de survivre c'est sûr
qu'on a fait des erreurs dans la vie
qu'on paye aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que
je dois encore travailler ça me dérange
pas travailler je me sens jeune en forme
j'aime travailler mais c'est quand même
difficile de mener alors à 79 ans yann
fait le barman comme lorsqu'il a débuté
dans la vie
aux etats unis 40 % des plus de 65 ans
sont dans cette situation une station
service au bord d'une autoroute du
michigan
arlene 68 en encaisse les plaintes des
clients et n'imaginent même pas accéder
à la retraite
pourquoi mais parce que je ne suis pas
mariée que je dois subvenir à mes
besoins
juste me relaxer oui ce serait bien
j'ai plein de choses à faire à la maison
j'aime bien cuisiner tout ça mais bon
dans un quartier populaire de chicago
des seniors en quête d'un nouvel emploi
viennent chercher de l'aide
ici à 62 ans lorna aurait préféré vivre
une retraite tranquille mais ces
économies d'une vie ont servi à financer
les études de ses enfants femmes se
trouvaient parfois dans une situation
dans laquelle vous on n'aurait jamais
imaginé se trouvait vous divorcez vous
avez 3 ans avait pas de travail
ben parce que vous avez été licencié
alors cet argent que vous aviez
économisés par ce choix
la location public ne suffit pas et
l'attention aux états unis
il n'y a plus guère que les
fonctionnaires tout soit désormais
assuré du paiement de leur retraite dans
la tourmente boursière de l'automne les
fameux fonction tv l'ont perdu 30% de
leur valeur affectant la plupart des
américains
et parmi les seniors qui travaillent
encore un sur quatre a décidé de
renforcer sur l'autre face à des jours
meilleurs